[موسيقى]
الاخباريه من قناه العربيه في الرياض
احتفلت العربيه بعيد تاسيسها العشرين في
مارس 2003 انطلقت من مجموعه ام بي سي وبعد
ذلك التاريخ بعقدين لا تزال رقما اساسيا
في فضاء الاعلام العربي
بحضور لافت من وزراء سعوديين وعدد من
الاعلاميين والفنانين
استعرض رئيس مجلس اداره مجموعه ام بي سي
الشيخ وليد الابراهيم الهدف وراء تاسيس
العربيه وما انجزته في عشرين عاما
ولدت العربيه من غرفه اخبار ام بي سي
لتكون المتخصصه والشامله في مجالها
ومنذ البدء
كانت مشروعا وطنيا سعوديا
بعد ان ظهرت القنوات الفضائيه الاخباريه
الناطقه بالعربيه
والتي سعى بعضها
لتوجيه الراي العام
وفقا لاجندات معينه
كانت في اغلب الاحداث تتخذ مواقف سلبيه من
المملكه ومن دون الخليج
طريق نجاح العربيه لم يكن سهلا ابدا
فارواح فقدت في سبيل الوفاء بوعد المحطه
ان تعرف اكثر كما
ركز سام بارنت الرئيس التنفيذي لام بي سي
في كلمته
يجدر بي ان اسلط الضوء على 18 شخصا فقدوا
حياتهم في سبيل خدمه قناتنا في السنوات
العشرين الماضيه ويجب الا ننسى مطلقا
المخاطر التي تواجهها طواقمنا والتضحيات
التي يقدمها الكثير من الصحفيين والثمن
الذي دفعته العربيه نفتخر بهم جميعا ونحن
ملتزمون بمواصله عملهم بذات المستوى من
النزاهه على مدار العشرين عاما القادمه في
اشاره على في بدايه طريقها اختارت العربيه
ان يكون نهجها هو المهنيه بعيدا عن
الشعبويه والدعايه
وكانت عنصرا في معركه التنوير بعيدا عن
العنف والجهل
كما يقول ممدوح المهيني المدير العام
لقناتي العربيه والحدث
العربيه لم تركن ابدا لتاريخها الطويل ففي
عيدها العشرين تعلن عن مزيد من التوسع
باطلاق اذاعه العربيه اف ام نعم انا مدير
محظوظ
لانني معكم في الرياض عاصمه المستقبل
وقبله المؤسسات العالميه الكبرى حيث تبث
العربيه نشراتها وبرامجها من استديوهاتها
وتستمر في توسعها
والياذن لمعالي وزير الاعلام وسعاده رئيس
مجلس الاداره
بالاعلان من هنا من الرياض باطلاق اذاعه
العربيه اف ام
لتكون الاقرب دوما والاقدر على استجابات
والاقدر على الاستجابه الاحتياجات الجمهور
المختلفه في احتفاليه عيد العربيه العشرين
ينظر مدير المؤسسه بعين الى ماض مشرف
وبعيين اخرى الى مستقبل تسعى خلاله
العربيه الى الحفاظ على موقعها في مقدمه
فضاء شديد التنافسيه